okay so what I'm going to talk to you
about today is how we partition systems
into micro-services some part of the
reason that I really got prompted to
have this discussion is that I've been
in to see consistently lots of bad
decisions about how people are
partitioning so people get the idea that
hey my team is gonna own a micro service
and we're gonna work on that
micro service and we're gonna be
independent from other teams working on
their micro services but quite often the
boundaries that I see people picking are
really just quite arbitrary hey what's
your team gonna do maybe we should do
this project okay well that's gonna be a
micro service and we're gonna get
ourselves into a lot of difficulty in
particularly there's a real nasty I
Japan called virtually entity services
or essentially your service is a micro
service and it just does some crud
operation it says up create one of these
read one of these update one of these
and delete one of these yeah I'm a micro
service if you're not right so a little
bit of a conversation today would be
about what is a micro service just to
clarify that and then we will talk given
that understanding of what a micro
service is how do we find it and I
apologize for those of you who are bored
with the conversation and what is in
micro service we will try and perhaps do
it a little bit of a different context
oh by most this is dull I'm old that's
pretty much where that says I am another
old white guy please we want less old
white guys here we could have a bit more
diversity to have be great
what do I say at the bottom basically
Factory is you know I am not smarter
than you I am just fortunate enough to
have basically had the right
opportunities to get to stand here all
of you could do this please speak a user
group speak please do lightning talks
please work your way up to get per
basically what to speak in front of
people it's a lot of fun you learn a lot
you get to travel the world we leave
less middle-aged white guys right okay I
also work on an open source product
called brighter there are some people
who work on brighten if
raise your hands you two go on hope the
general you're higher and we're
hopefully very friendly at least those
two are anyway and if you want to get
built a note for the project we do a
messaging systems and we've got a
mediator like if you know that for a
c-sharp but we also do between
microservices we have a Python version
called bright side the Python version
where we do with some friends and we
also read most of us work in things like
platforms like AWS or RabbitMQ on prime
etc we've already could do as soon as
you have people to come and help our
eyes your transport so please come along
without what's today's agenda we'll talk
about this idea really what's called
products versus projects and really that
is a key to understanding what micro
services are about when we basically
move on from that while they're getting
decided componentization vice services
and that's when we will describe what
the character is for micro service are
that are important to understand how to
create partitions then we'll talk about
this notion of organized around business
capabilities so Fowler and Lewis and
their original paper on micro service
said they are organized around business
capabilities what does that mean what is
a business capability and how do I
organize my micro service around it
right people read that sentence and I
don't know many people who necessarily
know what that means
I would also mention bounded contexts in
there we'll talk about why that's a bit
of a red herring and we're getting that
is a segue at the end independent of
probability because it's just a nice
little finish up to tell you about some
of the things you will then gain from
this process ok products not projects so
when I heard this particular phrase
before products not projects ok so the
only one products not projects is the
your team should be working on a product
not a project right in other words here
is a thing that we are building we are
going to continually iterate on we are
going to make it better and we're going
to they should but get they should be
success or making a better version of
this not on the 15th could we have done
this right very different strategies
and it Broughton anyone know who
Adrienne Cockcroft is a general code
Kraft is the what was the lead architect
of Netflix so if you watch Netflix this
is the guy that built a lot of what you
use and he was this as the people who
came up with effectively things like
history it still except her a whole
range of open-source products some of
which she may use this your particular
in chocolate and they called basically
what the approach they were doing
fine-grained SOA so fine-grained
service-oriented architectures and they
are one of the people all along probably
with say the famous Jeff Bezos email
Amazon which effectively said you know
your team basically you're going to
build a service it's going to stick it
behind an API I don't care what the API
uses and no one talks to basically your
database apart from you otherwise I
follow you
the famous vsauce email basically and
they are probably the two groups that
really originated what we think of today
a lot as micro services if the like
james lewis enlightened father were
really representing what they saw out
there in the marketplace and Adrian's
had this important thing speed wins in
the marketplace what does he mean by
that what he meant by that is he now
believes that it is table stakes in most
industries where you want to be
competitive to release multiple times
per day if you are releasing every two
weeks that is no longer good enough if
you are releasing every month you have
probably lost and the way to essentially
achieve that speed is microservices so
what's the problem so if I have a
monolith and typically and I'm a
successful business then it's likely
that I'm going to need to have multiple
teams working on my monolith a team is
probably less than 12 people pizza
people Amazon uses this model of T
pizzas some folks like to think of it as
five plus or minus two so up to about
seven but generally probably you are I
would accept if somebody said you are
the team lead and there are 40 people in
your team
we probably go I don't really want that
job thanks very much at the T meter 12 I
might go really six would be good okay
so if I'm gonna basically break up my
organization into a number of teams
I'm going to get a problem if the way
that I've organized my software is a
monolith and the problem I'm going to
get is that all those teams want to
release the code that they've been
working on in at the same time quite
often right so what tends to happen is
my team's go away and we've got some
repo that represents the monolith and
they will basically branch and they will
create some feature branches that say
we're bucking working on this feature
because we don't want to be working on a
constantly moving target which master
would be with multiple teams inside it
we've got like 50 developers it's going
to be hard
so we've branched basically our code and
we go where we work and we deliver and
build our feature where you get it
working well the top one is everybody
else is branched and so we're not
integrated with them so now we have to
go through integration and so we say
right well we're going to release and
I'm gonna release basically on the on
the 15th the world gonna release our new
feature and then usually what happens
because everybody knows it takes time to
release now in this model
everyone else goes all we tried to
release as well and you get a hold of
people stacked up basically to release
and generally what happens is you have
some kind of meeting and in the meeting
effectively all the wise people sit
around and they say what's gonna be in
this release and we all agree and sign
out and say that's gonna be ready this
is going to be ready if it's an
exception we get to have this release
meeting and ops are there and if I gets
very excited and then effectively what
happens on the 15th hopefully everybody
checks in code and says we're ready to
go sometimes some people are a bit of a
lag arts we then get a bit of delay in
the process or trying to sell well could
you go in the next release and then they
know that release is going to take time
so it seemed from the process they don't
want that to happen so they fight to be
allowed in thoroughly so you may get a
delay into the beginning of your release
process they all integrate our software
then we have to test it because we now
have to test all these integrate your
branches to see if basically anything
breaks
something undoubtedly breaks and then we
play pin the tail on the donkey because
it's not my team's fault that's broken
it's your team's fault that that seems
broken so some poor soul gets the job
probably the person that'll move fast
enough out the way having to diagnose
exactly whose fault this problem is then
go to that team and say hey guys your
code is broken they fight about it for a
while and eventually that team accepts
they need to fix that fix the bugs they
fix the bugs they really put the bugs
back and check that into the code we
retest everything okay
and generally what's happening is time
is now elapsing okay at some point we
may even get to the really horrible
situation where we say your code is so
buggy that we're not going to get out
for this date and I'm desperate to get
out for the stakes I promise the
customers I was going to go to go out in
the 18th and now we're going to be late
because your code which you checked in
from your team which you don't need out
until the 25th or whatever misty buggy
for me took me to put out and then you
have to horrible decision of can we
reverse out your code right and maybe if
we're lucky we've got feature switches
and we can say yeah we could deploy your
code just all the switches turned off
right that may be a good bet er world to
be in but often in my experience this
process takes about two weeks and it
becomes kind of this self-fulfilling
prophecy unfortunately that because we
know that it takes two weeks to release
anything nobody wants to miss the next
release train window for their software
and so we end up in this world we can't
release faster than two weeks and
actually we may release every month and
if our competitor is releasing every
single day what's going to happen is the
sales team they're going to go to the
CTO and they're going to say to the CTO
mmm the development seems very
unproductive all of our competitors
release much more software than we do
much faster and our customers say that
basically were too slow releasing stuff
right that's an uncomfortable
conversation when it happens
so how do you fix that right how do you
fix that
early cycle problem so microservices are
around slicing up our software so that
your team just owns a portion which it
can deploy independently of any other
team so I don't need to join the release
train anymore my better code that deals
with we're looking at we're going to get
a hotel example later which basically
does or what happens at check-in for the
customer basically into our hotel I can
add new features around there I can make
life better face you for the person
working on the front desk and for the
customer I can I can do all that work
and essentially I just release when as
soon as I as soon as it's ready as soon
as the story moves into the swimlane
that says done done I can ship it
because I'm not waiting on unlike them
on this team or that team I don't have
to integrate with them I've probably
deduct on master as a team with a behind
a feature switch in case effectively we
have multiple pieces of work but
generally speaking even in that model
the best thing to do is try and have
your devs all swarming on one story at a
time to move through the chain so you
can just release that story out and get
out the door right simplify everything
and your goal is to make it possible for
that team to ship without having to talk
to any other team in the organization
and they just keep iterating making the
product better releasing multiple times
a day if there's a if there's a defect
it's very easy for them to release the
code and just get a new version out very
rapidly and that's what a micro service
is ultimately built on doll the noise
about what you may think about lines of
code everything else the sole purpose of
micro services to allow teams to
independently deploy that's their that's
their is that's the whole reason behind
ok that's what folks say if there's only
four of you you don't need micro
services because there's only four of
you you're probably only working on one
thing and you can just release it right
it doesn't really matter that it's a
monolith or a mic or a micro service in
structure and your monolith can be a
distributed system so what other thing
is that sometimes people say I want to
do micro service is it what they mean is
that
to distributed systems because I want to
scale parts of my platform independently
from it from another the web process
that takes an HTTP request may not be
basically need to scale the same way the
worker process that reads work you've
put on a cue scales act that's a
distributed system a monolith can be a
distributed system right micro-services
is about alignment of teams to parts of
your system to allow them to move on an
independent schedule so this notion Sam
newman calls out a lot basically
independent deployability that's the key
characteristic you're looking for and it
have to ask yourself for any micro
service if you believe you are doing
micro service is the question you have
to ask yourself is is it independently
deployable and that leads to this useful
model called product mode rather than
project mode so project mode what tends
to happen is the head of product has
some roadmap and talks all these product
managers and says we need to build this
stuff on the roadmap and they go out to
basically the whole pool of developers
and they say right we need to take X
developers from the pool and we're going
to put them on this part of the roadmap
and they're gonna work on delivering
this feature and if you're lucky
essentially the same developers of tend
to be working on the same bits of the
code most of the time but if you're not
you just get randomly assigned a bit of
the code and told to ship a feature and
the key driver is usually a date right
we measure success by did we hit the
date that's pretty useless because the
date doesn't actually have any real
business value so product mode says I
work on a portion of the product I work
on something like how we do check-in and
how we do check out how we basically
make rooms available for customers to do
booking out what the booking process
works like how the payment system works
right and I have a backlog of work and I
simply take the next most important item
out of the backlog and I do it when we
measure success by business facing
numbers did we basically increase the
revenue from a typical customer journey
into our basically site by 10%
did the time it took for the customer to
complete basically the check-in process
dropped from five minutes to two did we
get the less customers signing on to our
site and then walking away after 30
seconds in frustration because the whole
thing is so bad they can't use it those
are the numbers that move the dial not
can we get something out on the
sixteenth and to do that you essentially
work around a product the team and the
product manager are focused on shipping
a better version of this product and
that has huge advantages if you if you
are a software developer because hey the
the effort I put into making this better
results in a better product the team and
I will all succeed so it's worth me
fixing that rubbishy code to make it
easier for us to basically deploy more
quickly it's worth basically me have it
I suppose you make putting all the
effort into getting the UX right so
customers can use it because we see
tangible rewards I'm no longer motivated
by I have to hit this date and I'll do
what's ever necessary to hit this date
and I'm motivated by I need to move the
dial on the success of the business by
making sure that this part of the
product achieves our overall goals as an
organization better right that's why
it's quite often aligned to things like
ok ours basically if you use those in
your organization then it down
from the top you're looking for key
metrics that you're trying to shift
instead basically of hitting particular
dates all right comparison of our
services so let's talk a little bit
about for me the history of micro
services are this reasonably quickly but
it's just useful I think to understand
where this came from so what's for a
time we some of us were lucky enough to
write things about common core bur and
there's a version of comm called econ
and so the commas are basically a binary
Interop standard between components and
it let you write a component like a
library in C++ and call it from Visual
Basic once upon a time the world
consisted of client-server apps written
a visual basic or power build they're
talking to C++ components
our comm standard okay I wanted to put
that common component running something
out somewhere else I hacked use a tool
called decon decon was distributed come
right from Maddie calm it was very hard
to get working
essentially the security behind it made
it very difficult he's a call from
boasting one machine to another and the
end what would happen in frustration you
would just say open all the ports this
didn't go down well with security is and
so decon was basically not succeeding
very well along comes like a Dom box so
I had done box ok don't box as a
Microsoft e-famous basically for working
on calm so broken and a WCF for example
was basically Dom box I'm so broken by
the experience he now works and Xbox in
gaming I think but he can he come up at
this idea and said well port 80 is
always open so what I could do is simply
cool the other object over port 80 what
I did I make this simple because it's
kind of a hack I'll basically put an XML
the name of the method I want to call
the parameters and I'll send that via
HTTP over port 80 and on the other side
I have something that essentially sits
there and listens the HTTP requests like
a server and actually makes the
impresses call effectively to my comedy
it's basically what the local court when
I come objet basically with these
parameters in that method name and guess
the result back and then effectively I
can send those up back over HTTP and I
can marshal that into the into the
calling object basically is the response
and it's got a hack and he decided with
I see this is my object access protocol
and it's really simple I'm going to call
it soap I've always were done this kind
of took off and we all start building
soap systems and then it went mad we had
WS specs and everything else effect and
we kind of lost our wire a little bit
there's something that turned out to be
basically that classic and it's a
hackathon I'm going to build basically a
bit easier we're talking between two
objects became a paradigm for an entire
industry but one of the good things that
came out of so was this idea of
service-oriented architectures this idea
that we could break up our platform into
a series of independent services that
represented effectively business
capability that's where this and all the
some of these ideas come from so that's
why one was effectively based on soap he
was sort of so it was a bad idea we
created but SOI 2
based around messaging and events the
vendors said we don't see making enough
money from this new idea of yours we're
going to create thing called the
enterprise service bus so the enterprise
service bus was this idea that said well
you've got these bits that are genuine
doing messaging but you've got these
legacy platforms and things that only
have database access etc and you know
what we'll put together this tool that
lets you hook all that stuff together I
said to be so it all talks to each other
even if it's normal actually SOA oh if
we're hooking everything together why
don't you just write the workflow inside
our tool head it's things like BizTalk
right the problem with that became is
you ended up with all these crud based
services that just did nothing but hey
savoured thing read update a thing read
a thing and all the business logic went
into the middle and there's that BizTalk
were phenomenally hard to get under test
you can write TDD against the BizTalk
workflow process and also essentially
your Co was effectively running
continually inside by soup this
enterprise service bus platform not
actually in your services so um Kaiser
comes a guy called Jim Weber Jim Weber
create something called guerrilla SOA
Jim says basically this is nonsense
that's the way is really great we've got
this idea of separate services but they
should just talk to each other via HTTP
and Jason or essentially some
lightweight message broke a light rabbit
right inside there called smart
endpoints and dumb pipes and as a whole
thought that happens over here Jim talks
to couple Fred George Fred George
basically is the guy behind programmer
and Mickey the program he says basically
the first thing we do we fire were the
product managers the second thing we do
we far all the QA z'd the only thing
that exists is developers talking to
customers oh and every serve should be
about a hundred lines long and kids 100
lines long you'll throw it away after
six months he won't write any tests and
it's like the cells in the body and that
was kind of extreme micro-services right
and the extreme SOA and the problem with
extreme s away because you disturb micro
services was it's created this kind of
like legacy right concept of all my
cells should be really small and be a
hundred lines exception are coming and
that results on fortune in a bit man ant
pattern we call nano services they're
far too small
and they just creates lots of
distribution without much necessarily
value but the Jim Weber model
effectively is very similar to what
Adrian was doing basically where so why
effectively Netflix and people like
Martin Fowler and James tears came
together and if actually said let's
create the name for this thing we call
it micro services so much services are
SOA and if they are SOA they really fall
under this notion of what we call the
four tenets of service-oriented
architecture signe one so3 right and dom
box of soap fame if I'm what you called
the four tenets and he said essentially
a number of important things the first
is boundaries are explicit this is very
similar to the Jeff besos email it says
the only way you get to talk to my
service is through an API and by API we
cooked me an HTTP we might equally mean
AMQP for messaging we might mean G RPC
it doesn't matter as long as there's an
API of some sort right and then what top
line a compacted my API policy
essentially means that's all agree on
whatever the protocol is that we're
using so that you're not saying I will
post a great service in C RPC and you go
oh I always wanted to use HTTP call you
let's agree what that's going to be and
services are autonomous says this must
be an independently deployable unit I
cannot have any dependencies that being
I can't deploy on my own schedule and if
my boundaries are explicit anything
inside nobody outside like to touch or
see my database or my coat right they
can only talk to it through the API so
that means I'm independently deployable
because I'm never going to have a
problem where I say I'm change the
database schema and you know that's
broken me that won't happen because I
own a database schema infecting the
tables that I use I'm never gonna have a
problem that I change the structure of
my code because you don't talk to my
code you talk effectively to my boundary
at the API it's one of the reasons we
say things like don't directly expose
your entities from your domain model out
basically on your API because if I
change my internal entity I don't want
the API to change and the reason for
that is that is the point of coupling
that's my contract with other people and
it needs to be stable
okay because if every couple of hours I
say I've changed the API again you're
not gonna win many friends in the rest
of the organization right when they go
down the pub it's gonna be you they're
talking about right so you want some
kind of stable external contract which
offers a service to other people and you
want to be independently deployable so
really you want to have something that's
basically coarse-grained enough to
represent a unit of functionality that
essentially means people won't have to
feel tempted to talk to you inside your
API essentially says we cover this
particularly responsibility and share
schema not types just about the fact
that most of us now work in
heterogeneous environments where you
know one team's working in Java and he
was working he go and other teams
working in dotnet and someone's decided
they're gonna deploy rust right that's
just the reality of lots of enterprises
today so if you share schema that means
that actually we can all get to operate
if I start sharing dotnet assemblies as
my main mechanism of interoperation it's
not gonna work right so good
microservices what basically exhibits
the usual properties basically of good
quality software and that they basically
will have strong cohesion and low
coupling that makes them stable right
this stuff all dates back to the 1990s
and basically a structured design right
I think it's the 90s it could be the 80s
I'm old okay so we can say for example
that micro services require common
closures a carbon closure is a property
of packaging that basically Bob Martin
defined in his book on kind of agile
software development and it says
essentially our package or a unit of
deployment things inside it should be
such as the same forces of change right
they should have want to change for the
same reason so if I have a service
oriented around the check-in process
basically my hotel it will change
because I want to alter things to do
with check-in right if I have something
to do with the occupancy in the hotel it
change because we want to do something
about how customers are billed for using
the minibar etc okay
and what we don't want is services that
have different reasons to change or
you're going to change if we change the
booking process as well as basically
doing check-in for a customer at the
desk
right we want to basically make it
possible that you don't change for both
reasons
and the partitions need to be stable it
doesn't really matter whether I'm gonna
use basically messaging between my
services oh I'm gonna use more and more
of a requester of an architecture I need
to be stable so the first thing is my
consumers my clients my guys running in
the iPhone the Android but to me the
guys doing web development they want a
stable contract right the guys doing
basically iOS don't want to have to ship
every week because it's a pain in the
ass game through the Apple Store right
so you want a reasonably stable contract
for them we want contrast between our
services to be stable the other micro
services don't want to have to
constantly keep changing because you've
changed your message format your API so
to do that we need to essentially pick
boundaries we can define reasonably
stable contracts for so how would we
pick a boundary that has a reasonably
stable contract what we want you need to
do is look at what the it is we're
modeling what is the business we're
modeling and seek out the stable
contracts within the business
what interactions in the business are
stable and well defined such that when
we automate them and use those as our
partitions we will basically benefit
from those stable boundaries and
probably we will find that when we look
for those partitions they are the ones
the business understands as being
partitions into our software and the way
it works all right
she's checking on the time to see how
I'm doing for progress my phone got
recognized my face at this distance okay
good one time all right so this is what
we get to this Frey ease that called
organizer basically anyone who's read
Martin Fowler and James Joyce's paper on
micro services see a view how many of
those of you read that had any idea what
they meant by business capability it's
just a quick question kind of 1/2 person
or to half people over there
all right people use this phrase
business capabilities and it dates
really from SOA era and unless you
really understand the history and
micro-services back to SOA it's unlikely
you can follow the path to find out
people talking about business
capabilities and what they were about
and why people thought that was a good
definition effectively for a micro
service boundaries should be okay
so
the key is we want to basically find
something the business might recognize
as a process boundary because that's
more likely to have change based on
effectively a product goal that is
effectively changing one component at a
time Nitori this slide is a bit heavy on
text what is a business capability so
business capability actually is how an
organization delivers service to its
customers and it consists of a number of
things it consists basically of people
because we may deliver to you as a
customer by using a process of talking
to you or writing something on a piece
of paper right if I go and buy something
in Starbucks there's basically a barista
who makes my coffee there's no cash it
who essentially takes the money from me
right so there are people involved
there's some knowledge basically
effectively someone has to know how to
make coffee right someone has to know
how to work the till system species
involved there are basically organizers
of structures and delivery models right
so there's a manager effectively he's
looking after the staff their delivery
models there's a Starbucks model where
effectively I go up an order at the
counter and they fill out the cup and
pass it on which is efficient as the
cost of model we're the same person that
takes the money makes the coffee we all
stand on line for ages and regret our
choices in life right so just a quick
aside so basically Costa it is
effectively why you don't do distributed
transactions anymore because Starbucks
had a better model right there's a
famous paper with Starbucks doesn't do
two phase commit and so what happens
that when I go to Costa is essentially
I'm saying there's a transaction which
involves all the components basically
all the services that need to be at
least to be completed in order for me to
get service right the yes the face you
take the money has to go to the counter
get the car make my coffee and hand it
back to me meantime everyone's queueing
behind me doesn't scale very well
Starbucks figured that out and it said
what happens is I basically take your
request I put it in a message which is a
cup and I put the message basically in a
queue and then a worker process which is
the barista comes
and removes the message from the front
of the queue basically makes your coffee
when it's made it goes down to the far
end where you're kind of waiting
basically for this asynchronous process
to complete and it scales much better
right and mostly you're going to go away
from this thing what is it going to say
what did you learn and he said we should
learn we should build our software like
Starbucks not Costa and that's fine okay
but what you're essentially using all
these people are stuff to do is to
basically deliver a process the process
in the Starbucks instance is basically
make Ian a drink a hot beverage right
make in his black American I know okay
and so make drinks is the process and
really although people talk about SLA
being aligned to capabilities from a
point of view of us discover any
reasonable boundaries really what we
care about is SOA is aligned to a
process and so basically back in the
dayy in SOA literature a guy called
nikolai disentis essentially said a
social represent a self-contained
functionality that corresponds to a row
of business activity as a process which
basically may sometimes be divided into
activities or tasks right so what you
want to look for is the process because
the capability includes your software
which is automating the process right so
when to wet the capability actually
includes the micro service automating
the process okay
okay process is usually defined by
basically of urban are now right so make
lunch or prepare a bill and a capability
is usually defined by noun on its own so
catering or accounting so basically the
process of making lunch is delivered by
the capability of my organization called
catering the process called prepare bill
is to live weather capability
mobilization called accounting some
folks like to basically use the
capability as the micro service boundary
so creating an accounting I think it's
actually probably better to use the
process because that's what you're
looking to automate because the
capabilities how we deliver the process
including use of technology right and
it's worth bearing in mind that you know
when people do this kind of analysis
they may decide actually you don't eat
or wear this at all
this should be a manual process or just
use a spreadsheet right so what we may
only be automating some parts what the
business actually does but one of the
things that you're trying to do to find
a process that says to say what does
this business dude what are the services
we deliver to our customers what are the
processes our customers go through in
order to get stuff done right example
we'll look at later is basically I I
used talk about hotels they never worked
in hotels so it's clear I'm not talking
about everywhere what someone where I've
worked so the PR department had to check
my suarez anyway and I always say and I
polished people basically Hugh work in
hotels and no one ever works in hotels
I'm running a course for two days
basically the messaging with some guys
that work on hotel software which is
kind of like never usually my big win so
but I do apologize if you work in hotel
software it's probably rubbish but it's
a good example cooler understand hotels
work but working in a hotel what I want
to do is look at the processes that I
need to do to service my guests right
I've got some take bookings and
reservations I want to check people in
there one check people out I've got a
food and beverage department that
basically says there's a bar where you
can buy drinks or coffee I'll make you
food and since you've are in service
that's the that's what my business does
right here it's effectively delivering
all those things to customers and that's
what I'm looking for is the boundaries
my micro-services around those processes
that the organization use is to deliver
alright so there are different
techniques you can use I'm gonna spend a
couple of them that I think actually are
usable but there are many others out
there so a whole field called business
architecture and we can't do that all
our business architecture in this time
frame so I think value stream mapping is
very useful value stream mapping
essentially originally comes much more
from the kind of Six Sigma lien style
enterprise movement where essentially
you're going in basically down to the
factory floor and tempting to remove
waste from the process and improve it
and usually when it's done in a Six
Sigma contest context you are for trying
to find the current state and then
essentially you determine what your
you've proposed what your future state's
going to be you know it's they're
already cut waste out of the process
right so it's a little bit more than we
need what we'll show you the whole
process and then we'll talk about how we
can kind of shortcut most of that
generally the process involves you have
some kind of kickoff meeting and you all
agree most important part of this is
I've been all going to agree with each
other the scope of what we're gonna try
and model don't try and bowl the ocean
you're really trying to look for one
given cut flow of how a customer gains
value from your from from your business
okay so what so the customers think
about the customers to do something what
is the process that leads from getting
value so what I'm going to show today an
example of is the customer wants to book
a room the customer then wants to come
to our hotel and check-in
Kuster wants to stay with the hotel
custom wants to check out a nice potala
Tina's just referred to as the guest
cycle okay but agree what the scope is
because you will have many possible
customer interactions and you need to do
a separate exercise for each of them
okay what you do essentially is you walk
the process now essentially if you're
some kind of Six Sigma lean guy this
means going down on the floor with the
shop workers and seeing actually how the
cars are made we may just need to
effectively find that so we might find
that's difficult you may find that's
easy if you can it's a good idea if you
can't basically that's where you get
some kind of customer expert who
factually explains the process to you
that goes on right
generally speaking the the reason people
try and walk the floor is because what
people think the process is if you talk
to a manager is generally not what the
process is when you actually talk to the
staff would do the work right somebody
in head office basically Acosta probably
believes they have the most fantastic
process for delivering coffee ever
invented and he has a lovely chart in
his wallet how it works and it's never
been running a single coaster in the
country right
that's the only explanation I can give
so much for Koster by the way I'm deeply
sorry so you did this walk and what
you're looking for when you basically do
the walk is to see where effectively
there are kind of handoffs or time gaps
because they indicate when one process
finishes and another one starts so I
look at the hotel example we see that
someone tries to basically look for a
room to reserve they're trying to find
something they're searching but you know
area or postcode in Google they've got
some aggregator site so actually that's
a step I'm looking for a room the next
step is basically now have you found one
I will then try and basically book a
room at the hotel I want etc generally
speaking the rule that the Li the Ling
guys give is you you really want to push
everything down to about five to fifteen
process steps right and don't go more
granular than that we will show you a
little bit later how you can go more
granular than what the value stream map
guys do because it may be useful T okay
then we make a layout so in other words
what we do basically we going to find a
big room with a whiteboard butcher paper
is what everyone refers to usually I've
never seen butcher paper available in an
office I've been in just a white boards
you stick post-it notes to it one of the
top is the customer and then you
basically stick post-it notes across the
whiteboard effectively to represent the
individual process steps so hopefully
you can see that and we think one up a
customer okay the first process in our
guests cycle of booking a room our hotel
is essentially the reservation as
inquiry process where essentially were
saying I want to try and find somewhere
to book for my lovely holiday in
Nottingham
well and so that's generally belongs to
a functional area which is basically the
marketing department right because it's
some kind of basically SEL to my's kind
of like it's gonna stuff out there then
basically we say all right don't work
you can't read this all in the
background I would say what they are
basically just to see the process
there's not much detail you care about
but then we say bye see I'm going to
make a booking which said generally
belongs to the reservations Department
right please make a booking for me then
essentially I'm gonna say I'm gonna
check in right so the customer actually
arise basically at their desk notice
that one of the things we can see here
is that there are time gaps right
between essentially well or handoffs
between me finding stuff and getting a
Google link and following it and either
getting to an aggregator or your own
site the process of making a booking
which will result in success or failure
of a booking and there's a time gap too
when I basically choose to check in at
the front desk and say hey I reserved a
hotel room in the hotel can I check in
please then there's a whole process
where effectively I'm now an occupant of
the room right and for the check-in
process the reason for this guests cycle
is that's important is actually the next
step when I check out they present them
with a bill for my misjudged use of the
minibar after I came home with won the
show but see many in my bloodstream
right when those Toblerone bars and that
packet of Pringles that really really
tempting even that wouldn't normally eat
any of them and what happens is you can
then do basically what's called a
reverse walk sometimes where essentially
you say when someone checks out what are
the artifacts that were likely to
basically give them we're going to give
them a bill how do we get the items on
that bill okay that must have come from
occupancy basically recording charges
against effectively you during your stay
etcetera right by the way don't build a
hotel system based upon my random
post-it notes it may have nothing to do
with how hotels work I don't accept any
responsibility if you see me for that
okay
then we can actually work so if we're
going to do basically a full-on
[Music]
value stream mapping process we've done
stream mapping and then what happens is
you do a second pass and add value and
generally what happens is in the value
stream a person's looking for a number
of things process time how long does it
take to process the actual individual
steps to someone needs to accomplish so
get back to the cost of Starbucks
example for example how long does it
take someone to actually make a cup of
coffee or ring up the cash John and you
get the lead time the lead time
basically says how long does it actually
take for you to that process to happen
when you account for delays and stuff so
for the point I arrive in Costa to the
point effectively I get my coffee is
that essentially a lot longer than the
point of the process for Starbucks
because effectively I've got a longer
lead times you two queuing right and so
you might look for example at your
checkout process and you might see what
the process time to do a checkout may be
basically a couple of minutes maybe we
could shorten that but maybe the bigger
problem is that you only ever having one
person on the checkout desk and actually
people are queuing waiting to check out
so my lead time is long even though my
process time is short okay and then you
can also look at percentage of
completion rates so you can say how many
of these things are successful it's
obviously more important I'm making
things about widgets in car factories
etc to do that but obviously there are
some journeys that are basically FL
anyway then you add those details to
this don't worry you can't read it I'm
going to show you another diagram you
fill them on the post-it notes and then
generally what happens is someone goes
through and produce something that looks
a bit like this this is a value stream
mapping diagram and you can see
affecting what we've got here is kind of
lead time and process time written in a
time line at the bottom and we have the
individual processes which I basically
have a name for the process which
usually is a kind of verb plus now that
I'm I I'm not occupying a room a bed of
occupancy a function which basically
Department tends to deal with that
number of people involved if there are
people and then lead time and process
time the completion rates okay and that
is what a value stream mapping exercise
tends to give you and that is well we're
looking for a candidate for a microt
service right mate booking that looks
like a candidate from microservice it's
a process it's well defined
any hotel I go to has probably got a
guest cycle that looks a bit like this
and probably has a process called me
booking that's where I want to build
microservices it should be stable
because effectively most most
organizations of a similar form will
need at some point to do a mate booking
process okay and it should be basically
a product because I can begin to do
things like say to product manager okay
when people land on the booking page
only 60% of people who start the booking
journey complete it try and improve that
let's get to 80 percent of customers and
basically make you through the booking
process to the end right and that's the
product you're working on the booking
experience as a team all right now we
don't need a lot of the stuff the value
stream mapping is giving us because
we're not really looking at current at
the future State so we can in our heads
actually just simplify to that really
that has it the whole exercise you can
just say that's basically the key
processes and the cycle and those are
the micro service candidates that I care
about okay however once that problem we
might here is what hang on a minute my
hotel software now the best in the
industry we have got basically growth
off the charts and we want to hire more
people and this model kind of goes given
us a few teams five teams so by the way
I should mention here is you do this
exercise for a whole load of processes
so I probably got more than five actual
microservices and some of these
processes may pop up in other than other
flows right so the value stream
essentially around the food and beverage
services in your hotel is probably
likely to include this occupancy process
if that's how we're basically recording
a bill for customers when they check out
end of the day so really I'm doing a
whole load of these and coming up with
the set candidate processes but it made
me they don't have enough processes for
the number of teams justy I can't even
remember it's like 700 developers right
now all right
which is huge numbers of teams and just
looking at the processes for how you
order your takeaway on a Saturday
night's probably not going to give me
enough to vision
it's what I then look at is basically
activities and tasks so the activity is
just a bit more fine-grained what
essentially happens during that mate
booking process tasks are a bit lower
level and tar supporting not great
candidates for us to worry about this
level for micro services because tasks
are something like effectively you know
enter customer register and to guest
registration details well that's
probably not as useful to me as
basically register guests which is the
activity rather than specific tasks I do
join that process and many of those
tasks will be manual or not even
automated so then I can look for
activities you'll notice that some of
them basically are shared right so one
advantage account this next level is I'd
maybe have to pull out shared micro
services that effectively can service
multiple processes so checking
availability of rooms registration
process making payments billing guests
it may well be that multiply to 'ti
level it's easier to see some
commonality I can break out to have a
micro service that is usable in multiple
value stream flows APQC which is
basically American something rather but
you can find them online they
essentially do it a lot around process
mapping and they define these five
levels so they basically say level 3 is
the process that's the one we want to
first we'll think about as I can pay for
micro services level 4 activities
suppose it's the other one we might
think about we've got a lot of teams and
then tasks are below them and then they
group them in processes and categories
which can be useful for organizational
purposes ok if you break down into
activities just be aware of what we're
talking about the empty service model
right I don't want to do this where
effectively I have these really crud
based services because I trouble with
these cloud-based services is that
effectively they don't contain the
business process logic and that will
then float up when you'll end up in
something you'll call basically a
gateway or an Orchestrator or something
like that and that will actually have
all of your process so this is a bit
like the OO problem we call feature env
when
essentially I've got a whole lot of
properties on my class and it turns out
the cooler understands the business
logic not the class that contains the
state right and the problem here is
exactly the same these micro services
contain the state but what they really
want is the business processes
associated with the state to be with
them not to be placed in this other
class that basically is orchestrating
everything right and you can get into
weird places or things like sagas and
stuff where effectively you've moved all
of your business logic way out of your
service and into some external layer you
want to avoid that you want to look much
more like the one on the bottom where
effectively I have a piece of work and
it's flowing through a number of
services in order to basically complete
which is exactly the model that's really
happening in your business you're trying
to model the reality of how business
works because that will end up with you
being more successful okay yeah this we
mentioned earlier essentially there are
a whole load of these you will
effectively find many of them you just
do a cross gonna like have them all lab
actually do get where you to go APQC
makes them off-the-shelf models
available loads of basically
consultancies were offered to sell you
an off-the-shelf model of processes for
just your business
caveat emptor you know but you can just
use useful here that anyone can see it
you can see here we've got a category
marking on products services within
which place we've got some process
groups perform customer mark analysis
which is quite a process perform
analysis which there are activities
inside identify market segments conduct
cut customer market research know that
these are not necessarily things you're
going to automate but we're talking
about modeling a process the
organization okay SOA traditionally one
of the top things that happen with SOA
is teams doing SOA transformation or
from going involved in business process
reorganisation projects because the IT
guys went away and said how does the
process work and then they discovered
how the process worked they said we have
two problems one is had to build the
software the other is your process okay
another alternative value stream mapping
events terminal event storming exercises
basically was very cool but to
Brandolini basically created this out of
the DDD community
so his idea was eventually to try and
basically model using events basically
he has this thing called the main event
and he says what we're initially gonna
do is figure out war all the events that
occur in a given stream basically for my
business and usually you're trying to
model something specific you can model
your whole enterprise I have some quite
ambitious target but you tend to mostly
model one specific flow that you worried
about and then he says basically any
event is triggered either by basically a
timer or a command this basically comes
into an aggregate or an external system
and generates that event so basically a
command comes along and starts from
transformation operation we raise an
event to show the results of that
command and then we can take events and
create a read model for the UI we can
take events and basically run them
through a policy and generate new event
and new commands so what does it look
like so similarly before basically the
first thing we do is we agree what
basically we're going to try and model
and then we do a school chaotic
exploration we whack post-it notes onto
the board that represent events in our
sequence you probably can't read in the
back don't worry so things like room
reserved payment complete booking
confirmed guests registered room
allocated these represent stages of
things that will have happened during
the guest check-in process where a
significant event will have a curb you
might want to record don't work if you
cannot see the post-it notes a my slides
are on github and be it's probably wrong
that's not how a hotel works right you
just know there's a whole drawer in the
slot orange posted notes represent
events that have happened in the system
okay now then you go and add the systems
and people so you say well where did
that event come from right so that event
is generated either by some kind of
person there's the smaller yellow notes
raising some kind of command or maybe
it's generated by a timer or a command
so reservation time would be basically
something that's saying hey you only
have a certain amount of time to
basically book this room and then I'll
time you out make you better than
somebody else for example right and then
effectively you get external systems
like payments and email that you want to
include
but these aggregates which especially
drive the which the command basically
mutates
basically create an event are the key to
understanding the outcome of one of
running one of these processes that's
got a great book about it I recommend if
you want to run one of these internally
you gotta read his book I can't explain
to you in five minutes how to do it but
I want to give you an idea okay then
essentially you do a walkthrough so you
basically say I am a customer what would
happen to me as they go through and then
you can do a reverse walk so just like
you do the value stream mapping and sort
the other end and say hey I'm checking
out where did all the bits bits I mean
they don't come from we do some that
just occasionally talking about art he
order flow we do ones that basically say
I'm a customer placing an order the
other one just says my food is arrived
in my door what happened to get it there
right okay and that means I can then
identify what are the aggregates and
they again may be key ideas we can use
to try and find our microservice
boundaries now there were external
systems here basically they may well
basically micro cells we care about as
well aggregates are potentially a bit
smaller than the kind of process model
you get from a value stream map and that
might be okay what you want to watch for
is this idea that basically but if you
model only aggregates as microservices
you may have a cluster of aggregates
that are also to the same forces of
change otherwise they have common
closure and you should group them
together for your micro service right
otherwise you're going to say well there
every time I change stuff in this team
this team has to change stuff to
probably put those two aggregates in
common closure in the same system okay I
like this it's really easy to do and
quite fun and doesn't carry some of the
overhead of value stream mapping that
comes from basically being used in
different contexts but the
identification of processes innovation
mapping is really useful sometimes run
both so we quite often do both and then
figure out what what it tells us right
the more the more view put more models
you have the easier it may be define
basically what you think is really going
on about it contexts so when people talk
about model of partitioning
microservices a common thing you will
hear as people say you find your bounded
contexts and then essentially that gives
you your microservices right
that is kind of not how bounded context
work
okay so bounded context for Eric is
essentially a set of boundaries in terms
of team organization code bases and data
schemas and he says essentially we can't
necessarily get to a situation where we
have 20 teams where everyone's going to
agree what the model for say a guest
reservation looks like because you may
want to do different things with it
right and rather than accumulate all the
possible information for all the
possible use cases in one giant thing
where my actual Microsoft's only process
is a tiny part of it what I do is
basically deal with the app that the
fields and data that I care about and
then have to basically say well if I
care about this part of reservation you
can write that part reservation we have
to model how we're going to interact and
most of what's called context mapping in
dddd is really about that problem space
or saying you've got this model I've got
that model how do they talk to each
other
and bounded contexts are in a diagnostic
tool we used to used to basically
identify that so it's kind of clear with
a micro service that because we have
basically one team looking after it
because essentially it contains insider
a model in code and a model in the
schema and essentially because we
consider it usually a continuous
integration boundary in other words if
something in here changes everything in
here but is then potentially deployable
then effectively it has what Eric calls
ubiquitous language the model is here is
it has to be consistent because we have
to agree with reservation means with
inside this scope so a micro service is
a bounded context right my definition of
what bounded context is and what
difference not a microservices they are
the same thing but this is typically a
mutt this is a monolith right
I could have multiple teams working on
my monolith they're looking at the code
which is contained with inside the
monolith and they're looking at the
schemer inside the monolith and there
could be consistent about the definition
of the code and the scheme and contained
within the monolith they could have they
will probably have to do CI over the
whole monolith which is part the problem
with the monolith so what did they you
have any bitterest language to
in their case they have built a really
large bounded context around their
microservice okay both of them abounded
context so bounded context of Norway to
basically discover micro services but
once you have micro-services you're
reducing the size of the bounded context
to be a micro service so much those are
a strategy for having smaller bounded
contexts right that makes sense because
I see a lot people talk about in the
context and they're not talking about
them right okay you're when you're the
way you find the boundary context is to
basically find the processes etc all
right am i doing right to minutes okay
almost there okay well just at the end
basically what happened there
okay well we'll make this work no more
info and deploy Bertie
so effectively inside the micro service
boundary you can use anyone one of a
number of strategies basically to get
working I think we're fine you can use
RPC to communicate between to basically
processes inside it you can use
messaging you can just share database
model use file sharing you can have
multiple processes inside a micro
service you're obviously gonna have at
least a database in your code so you've
already got to write but you can
actually have a worker processes as
async work because you're looking to the
problem of how do i scale parts of my
micro service independently of each
other for work but across micro service
boundaries because I want independent
deployability I only can really use
messaging an RPC because I can't use
databases effectively because that's
shared scheme which will break when
dependent of pliability and I've had
file transfer kind of could work but we
tend to just use messaging across micro
services all right so we basically have
a problem with independent operability
all right we're running out of time so
basically I will say roughly so what we
need to do in order to make success of
micro services is recognize what they
are for what micro services are for are
about you essentially scaling your
development organization by allowing
multiple teams to work efficiently
together to deliver for you
without getting each other's way and
your goal is to get those multiple teams
in a position where they can deliver at
will many times a day based on
effectively pulling items off your
backlog which is essentially oriented
around business metrics which move
forward the die on the given piece of
your product and that team just keeps
pushing their way through that backlog
making their portion the project better
we may we don't mention it earlier
because it's kind of like of course you
are going to get some pieces of program
where they get centrally dictated that
you're gonna have to conform to as a
team but most of your worship in that
product backlog all right
and finding processes or using
effectively event modeling is a way
essentially of trying to figure out what
those micro-service boundaries are such
that what orienting to units have
changed the business understands and can
create metrics around that are stable
and long-lived such that we won't have
to keep changing our boundaries in our
shape all right okay we don't have to
have four questions I am around you can
come and just talk to me I'm quite
friendly I promised my I am i Cooper on
Twitter my DMS are open if you'd rather
ask questions in private you can just DM
me and I will answer questions as and
when I can please remember to vote you
put the green ticket in the box or they
press the green button and then that's a
vote at the red tickets are not a vote
all right all right it's very much for
coming
[Applause]